patrícia RSA is the mayor of vin toe in
the state of Cochabamba on thursday she
was taken from her office and dragged
through the streets they cut my hair
left me like this my one mistake has
been to work for my people those who
attacked her are opponents of Bolivia's
President Evo Morales who have been
taken to the streets to denounce fraud
last month Evo Morales won the
presidency with a 10-point difference
his opponent Carlo Meza denounced fraud
when the vote count was halted for at
least 24 hours when the vote resumed it
showed a shift but favored Evo Morales
in santa cruz de la sierra the heart of
Bolivia's agricultural industry and move
is underway to disregard Evo Morales
presidency we are symbolically taking
over public institutions because at
meetings nationally we have decided that
Bolivians are not an agreement with the
fraud this fraud that has been seen
internationally we want the vote to be
respected by all citizens from Bolivia
violent clashes have broken out between
anti Morales protesters and those who
support him an example of the deep
divisions in this Andean nation Evo
Morales Bolivia's first indigenous
president continues to enjoy support
mostly in rural areas
his followers say Morales opponents are
racists and they vow to defend their
president we're calling for justice
prison for Camacho someone needs to pay
for their crime why Fernando Camacho is
the leader of the prasanta Cruz Civic
committee a group that has consistently
challenged over Morales since he won the
presidency in 2006 he arrived in the
capital La Paz to take a resignation
letter to Evo Morales the runner-up in
October's election Carlos Mesa said he
supported Camacho's move we believe that
we must do so through a new election but
we deeply respect a decision that he has
taken to present this proposal a
resignation letter our position is that
the president has to leave
democratically through the popular vote
and we have proposed a new election
this would be Morales fourth term in
office his critics say he has ignored a
referendum in which four Libyans voted
to restrict presidents to two terms the
Organization of American States is
auditing the vote and it is expected to
be completed before the middle of the
month
but until then tension is unlikely to
end any time soon terasawa
al Jazeera